hola buenas tardes cuéntanos
espero que bien bueno vamos a comenzar
con esto me hice unas preguntas hace un
tiempo
se les pregunto si a ustedes si están a
gusto con el trabajo que hacen si no
están a gusto con el trabajo que hacen
que están haciendo a lo mejor para
modificar esa situación para empezar me
gustaría hacer una especie de juego en
piedra papel y tijera creo que la
mayoría los conocemos alguna vez los
hemos jugado
vamos a hacer el piedra papel y tijera
levantamos la mano con la opción que
cada uno elija no sé si les parece para
arrancar con esto vamos piedra papel o
tijera bien perfecto me gustaría que
después al final se acuerden cada uno
ustedes porque no veo prácticamente
que eligieron
yo elegí tijera obviamente y no es
casualidad si bien me dedico a cortes y
demás no es casualidad el tema de las
tijeras
empecé a cortar hace mucho tiempo la
primera vez que corte fue por allá con
19 años
me tijeras en ese momento mis
herramientas de cortes no eran
convencional como éstas se presentaron
en distintas maneras se presentaron en
unesco en un par de copas en hacer
mandados en barrer veredas limpiar
sillas me tocaba hacer ese corte a los
nueve años con parte de mi infancia
tengo una familia muy humilde
entonces me tocó arrancar cortando con
la infancia en cierta manera creo que no
está bueno a veces que los chicos
trabajen no cortar con la infancia no se
veía mal me dejó mucho mejor mucho esa
experiencia haber arrancado así
y aprendí a valorar lo que costaban las
cosas
el valor de cada
usted que ni es que parecía así pero el
otro lado se veía que tenía un
sacrificio mayor el que pensaba hasta
ese momento me tocó estar del otro lado
del mostrador muchas veces mientras a
los mejores mis amigos estaban
disfrutando de alguna comida de alguna
situación muchas veces me daba el acceso
justamente esas cosas
e
pero me fue muy útil me sirvió no la
pasé mal y me dejó ese aprendizaje ya
desde chico seguí haciendo cortes a lo
largo de mi vida varios en este aspecto
[Música]
con 12 años tenía que empezar el colegio
y también casualmente de trabajo si bien
seguía detrás de un mostrador esta vez
iba a ser en la barra de un boliche pero
yo me conocen muchos de ahí
en esa etapa de la secundaria haciendo
otros trabajos en los tiempos libres la
mañana y los fines de semana trabajando
en el bar y en el boliche por ahí el
corte que hice fue el corte al tiempo
que uno le debería dedicar a un estudio
siempre con la pensar pensando que uno
o por lo menos yo quería estudiar algo o
ser ese algo o ser ese a alguien que a
lo mejor a gente de mi generación nos
inculcaban estudio para ser alguien
bueno término secundario
trabajo en algunas otras cosas tomando
autos ayudando operando albañil y
algunas otras cuestiones y a los 24 he
decidido hacer un corte llano laboral
sino en el trabajo en general y movido a
ocasiones a mar del plata no haya mar
del plata a visitar unos amigos para
pasar unos días
esas vacaciones se me hicieron largas de
8 años
miraba cuando las cosas porque no había
llevado nada siempre con la idea de
poder estudiar o hacer algo me gustaba
mucho la carrera de publicitario
arrancó la carrera publicitario para
arrancar la carrera de publicitario
tenía que trabajar otra no había
al poco tiempo de llegar consigo un
trabajo que afectando en la peatonal en
mar del plata llevando comida a los
locales shopping y demás
duró 15 días 18 de diciembre el día de
la virgen es feriado había una
entrevista laboral
el hombre que nace una entrevista entre
300 personas seguramente porque
temporada alta hay mucha gente que va a
ser la temporada se ve reflejado con mi
historia y me toma por eso por verse
reflejado con mi historia
consigo ese trabajo estable la primera
vez con 24 25 años un trabajo estable la
diferencia estable y en blanco a
diferencia de los anteriores que siempre
habían sido informales
con este trabajo tengo
energía como parecido tengo la
posibilidad para decir puede estudiar la
carrera que quería estudiar arrancó esa
carrera que quería estudiar trabajaba
el resto del tiempo bueno a los tres
años la carrera
y terminaba arrancado a las seis de la
mañana terminaba una de la tarde una y
media me iba a trabajar hasta las dos de
la mañana o más o menos según la
temporada del año cuestiones que
llegando el final de la carrera ha
pasado a los tres años
cuando me presentaba a hacer los finales
el equipo de trabajo que se había armado
no me parecía justo para mí y para mis
compañeros en ese equipo no estar a la
altura porque muchas veces leía
únicamente lo que mis compañeros habían
trabajado y me daban entonces después de
un par de presentaciones decidió cortar
nuevamente ay córdoba en el estudio
en ese tiempo
me hago amigo de unos chicos de la plata
que en mi situación también habían ido a
hacerse la américa peluqueros pero hasta
el momento yo iba solamente a visitarlos
a ver cómo era la onda pero desde el
lado que lo ve la mayoría de los
clientes
tanto tiempo me fue picando un poquito
más y siempre con esa idea de tener algo
o ser algo
decidí hacer el curso de peluquería
al curso de peluquería pero me dedico de
manera informal a hacer la peluquería
ocho años allá un día me vuelvo por
distintos motivos
me vuelvo sin nada
el que era mi jefe me había asignado el
tanque de nafta no me podía pasar nada
en el camino porque quería el perro el
auto con la ropa y me vine a arrancar de
nuevo
hacer ese corte y empezar
busco la posibilidad de conseguir algún
trabajo formal en relación de
dependencia pero sin suerte
vuelvo a los orígenes otra vez a la hora
auto pintor y demás changas
un amigo me ofrece trabajo en una
fábrica
estoy un tiempo trabajando con él dos
años más o menos
en ese tiempo ya era más más seguido el
tema de hacer cortes cuando estaba con
tiempo libre digamos por distintas
situaciones un día me di cuenta que no
estaba haciendo lo que quería no era eso
lo que quería hacer
y no quería tampoco que esa situación me
sobrepasará el día de mañana reflejado
en algún tipo de enfermedad en algún
tipo de estrés y demás así que ahí
empiezo a hacer uno de los cortes ya más
a conciencia en mi vida empieza a
guardar
de a poco empieza a dar forma al corte
de a poco me largo a trabajar de
peluquero pero consigo por medio de un
amigo la posibilidad de trabajar en
rafaela
empiezo a viajar a rafaela en el
colectivo de las 728 volvían el de las
11 me pagaban 80 pesos del día tenía
casi 50 pesos de pasaje y algo que comía
el mediodía
me venía con casi nada un visionario
para el negocio lo voy a dar en la
próxima charla cómo hacer dinero como
hacerse rico bueno
si me dio la posibilidad de aprender más
en el tema en mi tema si me dio la
posibilidad de encontrarme eso que en un
momento lo busqué por el lado de la
publicidad pero terminó descubriendo por
estos vaivenes de decir amo lo que hago
y siempre me preguntaba cómo hacían mis
amigos cuando estudiaban en el
secundario para saber qué es lo que
querían ser o lo que querían hacer
envidiaba esa gente que ya tenía esa
determinación esa decisión y uno a lo
mejor yo por ejemplo anhelaba algo pero
por verlo desde afuera el tema de la
publicidad porque no sé si haciendo
publicidad me iba a llenar lo iba a
encontrar eso que terminó en contrato
después
dos años después de viajar a rafaela
el corte más importante de mi vida de
corte más importante en lo laboral
decido largarme solo siendo hincha de
racing
pero independiente fui esa vez decidió
cortar con ese trabajo para trabajar por
mí
a partir de ese momento la libertad la
sensación de estar lleno
que encontré fue indescriptible y muchas
veces varios amigos me dijeron con
anterioridad porque no te largas solo
porque no te largas solo porque no tener
gas solo pero también siempre lo veía
digo desde afuera es fácil y por ahí hoy
yo con eso estoy reflejando mis amigos
con la charla de hoy desde afuera es
fácil decir lárgate sólo salí de la
estabilidad salí de esa comodidad
lo bien que me sentí en el momento
que lo hice no se los puedo explicar ahí
es donde me gustaría dejarle la duda
para que si alguien se anima a vivirlo y
le está pensando o está en esa situación
se anime
libertad para hacer lo que te gusta
trabajar sin que se te pase el tiempo
trabajar y no sufrirlo disfrutarlo y
después massa de lo económico
si es rentable si no es rentable si uno
es exitoso si no es exitoso va a estar
relacionado en la medida de lo que uno
quiera priorizar
yo podría haber anunciado distintas
situaciones también por ahí
anteriores o cosas que me tocaron pasar
de chico y que nos fueron llevando a lo
mejor a esto pero siempre con la idea de
tengo la idea de decir seguramente hay
gente que la pasó mucho peor que yo
seguramente hay gente que tuvo muchas
más posibilidades que yo creo que no se
trata de una comparación en las malas o
buenas que toca pasar a la gente sino se
trata de
medir la actitud o esa cuestión de decir
me animo lo puedo hacer muchas veces nos
vemos las tijeras que nos presenta la
vida hay que saber aprovechar esas
tijeras si son impuestas por una
necesidad si son medias forzadas por una
situación creo que no hay que frustrarse
al momento de usarlas sino hay que
sacarle el jugo hay que ver cómo las
podemos aprovechar pero si cuando vemos
que hay una tijera que nosotros podemos
agarrar no tener ese miedo de decir
agarremos la probemos empecemos a cortar
cortemos no va a ser fácil ni de un día
para el otro pero hago hincapié en la
sensación de poder hacerlo
es impagable es impagable
así que mi idea mi mensaje va por ese
lado si alguno está en
un momento en que duda de cortar con
algo que no lo está llenando que se
anime que va a ser todo todo para bien
que va a ser el todo positivo si el
objetivo está está claro
ideas ahora ver si a la hora de jugar un
piedra papel y tijera
cuando decidan levantar la mano estos a
modo simbólico entre nosotros pero el
día de mañana cuando ustedes juegan un
piedra papel y tijera para con ustedes
puedan decir hoy agarro la tijera el
corto con esta situación que a lo mejor
no me está llenando así que les propongo
hacer un piedra papel y tijera
piedra papel tijera muchas gracias
[Aplausos]